[MUSIC PLAYING]
ASH AHLUWALIA: My
name is Ash Ahluwalia.
I am a product manager for
the Google Cloud Platform,
and I work on transfer
products, products
that help customers
get data from wherever
it is into the Google Cloud.
And we primarily have, for
this session, three big goals.
One is to help you understand,
how do I get started
on a big transfer project?
Two, what options does
Google have available,
and how do they work?
And then three, what are
some best practices that I
can employ so that I can have a
successful transfer initiative?
So those are the three
things we hope to cover here.
So to start with, I want to talk
a little bit about the mission
of our transfer product suite.
It aligns really well
with Google's mission
to organize the
world's information
and make it universally
accessible and useful.
From the transfer perspective,
what that means is
we want to make sure that
your data is delivered
where and when you
need it so that you
can make it useful
for your workloads
and for your business.
Now, there are a lot of
different applications
of your data in Google Cloud.
You could be running
an analytical workflow.
You might be
archiving data as part
of your hybrid or
multi-cloud strategy,
or maybe you're retiring
some legacy infrastructure,
in which case you need to move
the data off of it before you
do that retiring.
And to be able to do all
of these amazing things,
you need, often as a first
step, to move your data.
And what I often find, at
least in my conversations
with customers, is that
it's easy to look at this
and say, oh, that's easy.
That's the easiest part.
We'll deal with that later.
But often, it's much
harder than it looks.
Sometimes you have
so much data--
petabytes and
petabytes of data--
the first problem is figuring
out what data you have,
and which subset of that data
am I actually going to transfer?
And then maybe let's
say you've figured out
what data you want to move, but
you don't have enough bandwidth
to move it.
Or maybe you've done
both of these things,
but now getting access
to data is the problem.
It's behind a firewall.
You need to get
internal approvals.
These are all
challenges that you
have to face when
you're moving your data.
And then finally,
sometimes you just
may not have the org resources.
There's nobody available
to actually say, move
the data now.
What we aim to do with
our transfer product suite
is to provide you
a set of solutions
that are simple,
reliable, and secure,
and hopefully,
remove or at least
minimize some of these barriers
to transferring your data.
Now, most successful
transfer projects
don't start from
moving your first byte.
In fact, they start
well before that,
in constructing a
good transfer plan.
And with that, I'd like to
invite my colleague, Scott, up
to the stage from Unity 3D.
Scott's team recently conducted
a very large transfer project,
and he's here to tell you
a little bit about how
you can make a great
plan and ensure success
from your transfer project.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT FARRELL: Hello, everyone.
My name is Scott, and I
work for Unity Technologies.
I'm a DevOps engineer
on the Cloud team,
and we recently utilized
a storage transfer service
to move a large amount
of files from S3 to GCS.
So what do we do?
Unity is the creator
of the world's most
widely-used real-time
3D development platform.
And what were we transferring?
500-plus terabytes of many files
varying in size from S3 to GCS.
Unity was in the process
of migrating many service
infrastructure
components to GCP.
So we had several
challenges and requirements,
and one of our
first requirements
was no downtime
for our customers.
Another requirement was
ensuring that all of our files
made it to the end bucket.
We had some files--
actually, many files-- that had
an older legacy naming pattern,
so we had to take
extra precaution
to make sure all
of them arrived.
So some of the requirements-- or
actually, the challenges we had
were updating our
service code prior
to handle this
no-downtime scenario.
We also couldn't
use the web console
for this because
of the complexity
and the number of files.
So we utilized the
STS API directly,
which helped us keep track
of the actual transfers
as they were happening.
So how did we
organize as a team?
First of all,
another team in Unity
had already done a
transfer project.
Theirs was slightly
less complicated
because they had
naming conventions
that were consistent.
So we essentially took some
of the code that they had,
some wrapper script, and
tailored them to our needs.
So our devs did a service code
prep to deal with where to read
and where to write files
during this process.
And so DevOps prepared scripts
to test these transfers
from our dev and
stage environments
before the final production run.
So once the developers
deployed the code,
we did the storage
transfers from dev in stage,
and we did things like
transfer speed times,
logging any errors
recorded, and test
runs to pave way for
final production use.
So some of the
tactics we used that
led up to this transfer event--
speed tests were performed
for transferring the files.
We did it in both regional
and multi-regional buckets.
The end bucket was
multi-regional for us.
So we also tested a few
transfers with smaller data
in buckets that were
in the same regions
or close to the S3
and GCS regions.
The final process
was for regional.
Actually, we transferred from
regional to regional and then
inside of GCS, we did
multi-regional transfer.
So some of our key takeaways
and best practices--
these transfers
can be complicated.
So devs and DevOps
worked together
to break down the process.
Also, I suggest
if your team can,
find any internal experts that
have done this transfer before
because you can learn from
what they've gone through
and maybe adapt your
transfer from their transfer.
So how to prep for the transfer?
Do lots of testing.
So testing will
help you understand
what to do in case you have
problems in the production run.
It also gives you a good
benchmark for performance.
It also may impact
your production code,
so know what your workload is.
Also, consider the
cost of transfer.
We transferred over
public internet from S3.
So you have egress costs.
Some best practices.
Evaluate all your
transfer options.
Also, consider temporary or
regional buckets for your sync
before you go multi-regional.
So if you have to sync again
you can have time to sync
to your single regional
bucket and then decide
what to do from there.
Have a really good plan.
Another final suggestion is
have service accounts ready
with STS roles.
You're limited to a certain
number of jobs per day,
so if you run out of
jobs, you can always
use one of your other
service accounts
that are ready for the process.
And most of all, prepare
for any issues or mistakes.
ASH AHLUWALIA: [INAUDIBLE]
SCOTT FARRELL: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ASH AHLUWALIA: Oh.
I have this for you too.
Thanks.
Thank you so much,
Scott, for sharing
some of your experiences
from your transfer project.
So one of the questions
that'll come up
as part of your
transfer planning--
or a very common
question that comes up--
is, how long is my
transfer going to take?
Now there's a big component of
that, which is what Scott just
talked about.
All of the process,
organizational work, testing,
and prep leading up to
the transfer event, that's
a big portion of the time for
a transfer project to complete.
But once you've
gone beyond that--
if you're talking just
about, I have some data here.
I have some bytes, and I need
to move them over there--
typically there
are two big factors
that drive transfer times.
The first is how much data
are you going to move,
and what bandwidth do
you have to move it?
So just to get a sense
from people in the room--
and I'll try my best to see
your hands with this light--
how many people in this
room have a connection
to the public internet
or to Google Cloud
directly that's more than
100 megabits per second?
OK, a few hands are up.
How many of you
have a connection
that is faster than one
gigabits per second?
OK, just one or two people.
OK, one last question.
How many of you have no idea
how fast your connection is
to GCP or the public internet?
OK, a lot of you.
So for those of you
that are in that bucket,
you already know
one of the questions
that you need to start asking.
Now, based on the answers
to these questions,
you can get a pretty wide
spectrum of outcomes.
Your transfers can take
anywhere from minutes or hours
to many days or even weeks.
So it's important to
understand this upfront,
and it helps you clarify what
options you should consider.
Now, another way
to think about this
is to think about how
"close," quote, unquote,
or far your data is
based on your bandwidth.
So on the very left-hand
side of this spectrum
here is data that you could
consider close to you.
So say, for instance,
you're moving
data within Google Cloud,
between two Google Cloud data
centers.
That's going to go over a
very high-bandwidth pipe
that Google has provisioned.
And so even if you're moving
a large amount of data,
it's going to show
up pretty fast.
In that sense, that data's
is pretty close to you.
Whenever you need
it, you can get it.
Whereas on the other
end of the spectrum,
let's say you have a data
center outpost on a mountaintop.
It has a satellite link
that's really slow,
or maybe it has no connection
to the internet at all,
in which case, even a
small amount of data
will take a long
time to get to you.
And so that is a way to think
about data that's far away.
So this is the
spectrum on which we're
thinking about talking
through the options that
are available for moving
data in Google today.
So we'll start with
the leftmost, which
is data that's close to you
with the Cloud Storage Transfer
Service.
Now, this product
is specifically
optimized to move data from
other clouds into GCP--
for instance, if you're
moving data from S3 into GCS.
And it's used for a lot
of different purposes.
Customers sometimes use
it for archival and backup
as part of their
multi-cloud strategy.
Sometimes they'll use it as
part of an analytical workload.
They'll load data
from S3 into GCS,
and then put it
into BigQuery or run
some of our machine learning
products against it.
Or they might be just
moving data within GCS,
moving between a GCS bucket
in one region to another.
Now today, this product
supports pulling data
from S3, GCS, and any
web-addressable HTTP data
source.
It can move data just one
time, or you can set it up
to run transfers every day,
like every day at 6 o'clock,
move my data over, please.
And it's supported
wherever GCS works today.
So what I'll go through now
is just a quick walk-through
of how this product works.
It's a pretty simple product.
First, to find it, you go into
Cloud Console our web GUI.
And you go into Storage,
and underneath there
will be an option
called Transfer.
If you click on that,
you will have the option
to create a transfer.
Pretty straightforward.
And when you create
a transfer, we're
going to ask you
for three things.
What data do you want to move,
where do you want to move it,
and when do you want to move it?
That's it.
So the first thing, what
data do you want to move?
So in this example, we're
moving data from an S3 bucket,
so we'll ask you for your bucket
name, your access credentials--
so we can read the data.
And then we also have
some optional filters
you can give us.
So if, for instance, you wanted
to move only the files that
were modified last week, we can
filter that out and only move
that data for you.
The second step is
to tell us, where
do you want to move
this data, which is
very similar to the first step.
Just tell us what GCS bucket
you want to move the data into.
As simple as that.
And then, finally, you tell us
when you want to move the data.
You can start moving the data
right now once you hit Done,
or you can schedule
it to run nightly,
as I mentioned before,
if you want to have
this be a continuous process.
So it's just that simple.
And once you kick
this off, there
is a reporting GUI that
will help you track,
OK, where all your transfers?
How much data has been moved?
How much data is left?
If there are any errors, you
can go look up the errors
and resolve them.
And it's just that simple.
No provisioning to do.
No other setup.
Just give us your credentials,
tell us these three things,
and you're ready to go.
Now, the next step
on the spectrum
is if, let's say, your data
is a little bit further away.
So perhaps it's
a networking link
that's provisioned by your colo
or you provisioned yourself
at your corporate
office data center,
so it might be a
little bit slower.
For that, we have a
product called gsutil.
gsutil is designed to move
data from your data center
that you operate
into Google Cloud.
It's a command
line utility, which
means you can use it
in an ad-hoc basis
in your day-to-day workflows,
just invoke it from a shell,
or you can put it in a
script as part of a cron job.
It works like any other
command line utility.
You can also run it
in a continuous mode.
So you can run it
in the background.
It will sit and
listen on a directory.
And whenever new data comes
in or data is updated,
it will push that
data to a GCS bucket.
Now, in addition to
these two modes--
continuous sync and copy--
it also supports streaming.
So if you have a Unix
command you're running,
you can pipe it to gsutil,
and it'll stream the output
to a GCS object.
Underneath the covers, it also
supports automatic retries,
encryption, and GCS
object versioning.
Now, gsutil has
a lot of options.
I'm going to go
through a few that I've
found in my experience customers
find to be pretty useful.
So let's just walk
through those now.
So the first is, how do
I get this to go fast?
One option I always recommend is
to use the -m flag for gsutil.
What this triggers is that
it runs the gsutil process
in a multi-threaded mode
so that many, many threads
inside the gsutil process are
pushing many files in parallel
to the cloud.
You almost always
want to use this.
Now, let's say
that's not enough.
Let's say you have--
running gsutil, and it's
using up three gigabits
per second of your bandwidth.
That's pretty good.
But you have a
10-gigabits-per-second link.
So how do I use up my bandwidth?
So what we recommend
there is to run gsutil
across multiple hosts
or multiple processes.
What you would do is
partition your data upfront,
and then you'd kick off multiple
gsutil command line invocations
to run the data
transfer in parallel.
So for instance, I run
gsutil on subdirectory one.
Then I run gsutil
on subdirectory two.
And then I run gsutil
on subdirectory three
on machine number two.
And all those gsutils
are run in parallel,
and that way, you can
fill up your pipe.
Now, let's say you do this.
You're still going to
have one other problem.
What if I have a really big
file, a 100-gigabyte file?
Well, it's going to get
mapped to one thread and one
of these gsutil
processes, and I got
to just sit there and wait
for that thread to finish.
That's going to take forever.
So for that scenario,
we have a feature called
parallel composite uploads.
What it'll do is,
for large files,
it'll break those
files up into chunks
and transfer the
chunks in parallel
so you don't get bottlenecked
on large files in your transfer.
Now I'll just go through a few
other assorted tips and tricks
with this tool.
The first is
controlling bandwidth.
So in some situations,
some customers will say,
I want to be able to limit
how much bandwidth gsutil uses
so that I can preserve
some of my bandwidth
for my existing workloads
in my data center.
And unfortunately, gsutil
still has no native support,
but you can use command
line utilities like trickle
to control how much
bandwidth gsutil is using.
Second common ask is--
especially if you're
doing archival-- is,
I want to say my file metadata.
How do I do that?
So you can use -P
option on gsutil,
which will preserve all
of your POSIX metadata
into GCS object metadata.
So it will preserve
that for you.
And then finally,
for people that
are worried about accidental
overwrites, you can use -n.
And that'll ensure that if
a GCS object already exists,
gsutil will not overwrite it.
So if that's a concern, if
someone fat-fingers something
or you just want to
make sure you never
lose data, that's something
you should look into.
Now, as I said before,
gsutil has a lot of options.
This is just a very
small subset of them.
If you're curious
to learn more, I
suggest you go and look at
our online web documentation
on gsutil, which is a pretty
comprehensive listing of all
the things that gsutil can do.
And with that, let me hand
it off to my colleague, Ben,
who will talk about some
other transfer options.
Thanks.
BEN CHONG: Thanks, Ash.
All right.
So that's me.
I'm another product manager
on the Google Transfer team.
All right.
So we have talked about
cloud transfer service
for cloud-to-cloud transfers.
We have talked about gsutil
for on-prem-to-cloud transfers
where you have a reasonable
network connectivity.
What about locations where
you don't have network
connectivity or not enough?
We have a lot of
customers who do
e-commerce, who serve content
from their data centers.
So you would think
that a lot of them
would have enough bandwidth
to upload terabytes of data
to cloud.
The reality is that they
use all that bandwidth
for production use--
to serve content,
to run e-commerce.
You don't want to suck
up all that bandwidth
to upload a few hundred
terabytes of data
to cloud and bring down your
whole system and your business
as well.
And the other option is,
well, why can't we just
provision more bandwidth?
It's not as easy as that
because of cost, of time.
You have to sign maybe
a two-year agreement
with your ISP.
And if you are just doing
a one-time transfer,
it's probably not worth it.
So that's where we talk about
the offline transfer use
case for situations where
you have very little network
bandwidth or you have no
bandwidth at all-- for example,
you have a data center up
in a mountain somewhere.
And Google's product is
called Transfer Appliance.
So the picture of the
appliance that you see here
is a 2U storage server.
It can be racked in
your data center.
It has a usable capacity
of about 80 terabytes.
And this is really inexpensive.
We ship it to you overnight.
You rack it, load data to
it, ship it back to us,
and we'll upload
the data for you.
Before I go into use
cases, the picture here
is of our bigger appliance.
It's a 4U form factor, usable
capacity about 400 terabytes.
This is a pretty big box,
so most of our customers
will have this sitting on
their data center floor.
So let's talk about use cases.
Number one use case here,
which we encounter very often,
is where customers
really like the idea
of running their workloads in
cloud, machine learning, data
analytics, and so
on and so forth.
But then they run into a
chicken-and-egg problem.
You have all that data.
You cannot convince
your CIO, CEO,
to fund larger network pipes.
So how do you get all
that data to cloud
to prove that cloud has
value for your company?
So we have customers who order
an appliance, just a small one,
TA100, ship us 70
terabytes of data,
run ML, run some data
analytics, say, hey, it works.
There's real value
for the business.
And that's where they get
agreement from management
to invest in more
network bandwidth
and so on and so forth.
Other use cases, including
seeding backups to Cloud,
and we'll talk
about that in a bit.
Data center migration,
large archival moves.
So where you are shutting
down a data center,
you may want to move
all that data to cloud
before you actually shut it down
and obsolete your old service.
All right.
So how do you get one?
The Transfer Appliance
service is now
available in the US and Canada.
It's also available in the EU.
You basically
order the appliance
online on Cloud Console
under the Storage section,
and you basically
fill up this thing.
This is how you fill it up.
There's a contact
email that's optional,
but how we work this
service is that it's not
automated at the back.
So what I like to say is
that there's a human being
behind the service.
So that's a nice thing because,
Ash was saying earlier, moving
a lot of data is not easy.
We don't want to ship
you the appliance
and like, go figure it out.
So we would like to work with
our customers hand-in-hand
to make sure that your
data moves are successful.
Again, the onboarding
process is very easy.
You request an appliance.
We ship it to you.
You fill it up,
ship it back to us.
We will upload the data
for you, and then you
figure out where you
want to put it in Cloud.
One note.
How many Canadians
are here in the room?
No, I don't see anybody.
One.
OK.
So how this works for Canada
is that the data upload
will be based in the US.
We haven't set up a
center in Canada yet.
So we'll ship you the appliance.
You ship it back
to us in the US.
We'll upload the data.
And in case you're worried about
security, the next two slides
from now, we'll talk about that.
OK.
So setup and configuration
is pretty straightforward.
This is a standard
server like those of you
are familiar with the
IT hardware, the picture
that you see here is the
back of the big server
standard power connectors,
standard copper ethernet
connectors.
And we also support fiber optic.
We do provide the
SFP+ transceivers.
There's some bandwidth
incompatibilities
across different
standards, so we'll
work with you to figure
out whether what we provide
is sufficient for your network.
And we also support
network aggregation.
So you see here there
are four network ports,
so we can run as fast
as 40 gigs per second
so network is not
in a bottleneck.
And talking about
bottlenecks, a lot
of times when we
work with customers
who have lots of
very small files,
they complain that copying files
from the existing file servers
[INAUDIBLE] are too slow.
It is mainly because of
the billions of small files
that they're trying to pull out.
This is something
that customers will
have to deal with, kind of like
reading data from the files.
Obviously, once
that data has been
[INAUDIBLE] from the
original file systems,
everything else is pretty quick.
OK.
So talking about
security, the key point
here is data is always
encrypted at rest, in transit.
We, Google, don't need the
keys to upload your data.
So customers keep and
control your keys.
The data is encrypted when
it's copied onto the appliance,
and customers will decrypt
the data in their GCP project
once the data has been uploaded.
And then what happens
with appliance
after you ship it back to
us and after the data has
been uploaded?
We do a secure wipe
of all the drives.
We reinstall the
OS and applications
for the next customer, so it's
like getting a new appliance.
So a quick security summary.
So you, the customer,
owns the encryption keys.
You manage that.
Data is always
encrypted in transit.
We upload the encrypted data
into what we call a staging
bucket, and then you decrypt
that within your own GCP
project.
And then we wipe the appliances.
Wipe certificates are
available, obviously,
for a lot of customers.
They find that it's very
important for audit purposes.
With that, I would
like to hand you off
to Deepak, who will talk
about one of the use cases
for Transfer Appliance.
DEEPAK VERMA: Hi.
My name is Deepak Verma.
I'm director of product
management at Commvault,
and we're one of the vendors
that support Transfer Appliance
on-prem.
So I'll start at
10,000-foot level.
This is our blueprint
architecture
of what we can perform
with Google Cloud.
So break down the architecture.
On the left side,
we've got a lot
of customers that are running
various type of workloads.
It could be VM workflows
databases, applications,
not just flat files that
may need to get transferred.
You've got a
Commvault component--
we call it the VSA--
that's capable of transferring
or writing that data into a GCS
bucket directly.
Transfer Appliance is something
that we supported recently
as a mechanism to transfer
large amounts of data,
and I'll get into one
versus the other one.
Once you're in GCP, you've
got a number of options
that you can use.
First off, you can obviously
protect GCU workloads,
virtual machines,
and applications
within those
workloads just as you
would on an on-prem environment
and write it to a GCS bucket.
Other components of GCP that
we support are Filestore.
So you can back that up as
though it were an on-prem NAS
and write that data to GCS.
Within GCS, we support tiering
just like you would in on-prem.
You would write to a
standard tier data.
And then maybe after
a period of time,
you want to move that to cheaper
storage, to deeper archive,
you can move that
into a cold line.
So you've got
flexibility to do that.
And one of the things
that I put on there
is actually protection to-from.
So not only can you
read the data from GCS,
but you can also write to GCS.
In other words, GCS protection.
So I want to double-click on
the Transfer Appliance component
and talk through use cases
that customers have brought up
to us.
So the first one is
migration of existing data.
So what this means
is there may be
hundreds of terabytes
or petabytes
of data that may
be sitting on-prem.
Typically where we've
seen it is elimination
of those long-term silos.
Some industries have
seven-year retention.
Others have up to
30-year retention
that they must maintain data.
And today, it's sitting
in tape libraries.
It could be sitting in
virtual tape libraries.
It could be sitting
in dedupe appliances,
and they want to
move that to Cloud.
So going back to
Ash's comment earlier,
it just doesn't make
sense to put hundreds
of gigabytes of
network connectivity
to get that transfer done.
So this is where
Appliance comes in handy.
So use case there
ends up becoming
what we call an auxiliary
copy, which is basically
making a copy of
that data, putting it
onto a Transfer Appliance, and
then bringing it up into GCS.
The second use case is seeding.
So maybe it's a net
new project where
they want to forego old
data, so we're going
to start backing up to GCS.
However, for the amount
of data that we have,
there's no option
to perform a full.
So I'll get to an example
here pretty shortly,
but the full would take a
considerable amount of time.
And you don't want to
size your bandwidth
for that full capacity
because you're not
going to be doing full
backups on a daily basis.
So we call this a full
or a baseline backup.
The third use case is
pretty interesting--
it's popped up more--
is air-gapped.
And this is more for
ransomware protection
where you truly want a copy
of data that is not tied
into your production network.
So there are cases where
customers have actually
put their data into
a GCS bucket knowing
that they can recover
in Cloud if they ever
hit that eventuality.
The benefit that you get
from a backup product,
driving that is--
obviously you're overcoming
bandwidth limitations
with integration of
Transfer Appliance,
but you get the benefit of the
deduplication and compression
as opposed to just copying
the data flat, if you will.
You have the ability
to perform encryption.
So Ben mentioned encryption.
However, you can still do
encryption at that level.
So if your backup data
is already encrypted,
that encryption
transfers through.
And the other benefit-- if you
remember the architecture from
the previous slide--
you don't need any additional
appliances or gateways
in order to actually move the
data to Transfer Appliance.
So it becomes a seamless.
So we treat, from an
architecture standpoint,
Transfer Appliance as though
it were an on-prem GCS bucket.
And where that comes in
handy is that once the data
has been moved to
GCS, then you don't
have to worry about having to
change formats on that one.
So adding a few components
to Ben's steps here--
so I've changed it from
four steps to eight steps--
you perform the ordering,
you do the setup, et cetera.
And then there's a component
of what to transfer.
So within the Commvault
infrastructure,
you can actually
run reports that
will tell you about the data
itself, when it's been touched,
what files it is.
So you can really select
what specifically you
want to transfer here.
Typically, what customers have
gone for is they'll select,
I mean, anything beyond 30 days.
So they'll consider
zero to 30 day
or zero to 14 days
operational recovery, things
that they need on-prem
to recover immediately.
But then beyond that,
they're maintaining
long-term retention,
and they want
to transfer that type of data.
Or they're going after
large static files,
so you can run
reports against that.
When you transfer
the data, you've
got two options, as
I mentioned earlier.
You've got the ability to do an
auxiliary copy, which basically
means it's sitting in a
backup format somewhere--
VTL, tape library, et cetera--
and you want to make
a copy of that copy.
Or it's a full backup
that you're baselining.
The next step ends up being
disabling any further writes.
So once the Transfer
Appliance is full,
we want to completely disable
any writes and data aging.
Why?
Because it's going
to take some time
to transfer the actual
physical appliance, to ship it,
to stage the data out.
And in that meantime, if
you've got policies setup that
may want to expire data based
on your SLAs or your business
requirements, it's not going to
be able to find that appliance.
So that's something
to keep in mind.
The other aspect is, what
happens to daily transfers?
And one of the things that
we've found is that it's very
beneficial to have
the daily transfers--
especially as GCS it's going
to be your ultimate target--
to actually have those sent
to GCS as incrementals.
And I'll get to a little
bit more around that one.
Then you ship the appliance.
You rehydrate the data,
as Ben described earlier.
From there, once
the data actually
ends up in your GCS
bucket within GCP,
all you have to do within
the Commvault interface
is actually flip a bit to
tell it that now you're
writing in a Cloud
library as opposed
to a pseudo-Cloud library that
was emulated on the Transfer
Appliance.
And why this is important
is because we're
going to use your
credentials and your roles
within GCS in order to
get access to that data
and to write new data.
You enable rights
and data aging,
so we can treat that
as though it were
your data sitting within GCS.
And you can do a test restore--
highly recommended.
And then you can
continue using GCS
for your incremental backups.
So the first real quick
high-level best practices.
From a deduplication standpoint,
of the things that we've
found with the
Cloud storage is we
can use very large
deduplication sizes
because we can do a range reads
within those blocks of data.
So where we've seen
customers trip up,
especially when
transferring data,
is on-prem they may be used
to writing a much smaller
deduplication block size.
However, when they
transfer that data
as an auxiliary copy into
Cloud, it's not optimized.
So then they have to do
a rehydration and then
a deduplication over.
So the first time around
to Transfer Appliance,
it's beneficial to just
have the right large block
size for deduplication sets.
It's one of the best practices.
The other one is to
definitely disable
the backups and data aging.
What that helps with is not
upsetting your SLAS on-prem.
That way the system is
aware that that data
is going to be inaccessible
for a period of time.
And one of the benefits you
get is you don't have to,
with the platform,
have the fulls
sitting readable,
available in order for you
to continue doing incrementals.
So obviously, from a
restore perspective,
you've got to be aware of that.
And by disabling it,
then you'll know what
restores are not available.
And then sufficient
bandwidth for
interim and daily incrementals.
And really, this is
the sizing question of,
do I want to size
for peak, or do I
want to size for incrementals?
So you still want to
consider your incrementals
and start writing those
incrementals straight to GCS.
So what I really mean by that,
I illustrated on the right side.
So for super simplification,
let's assume you've
got 500 terabytes of data.
You've got a gigabit bandwidth
available to do the transfer.
And let's say you've
got about 2% change
rate of net new data coming in.
One option is you
write the 500 terabytes
as is through the
Transfer Appliance.
Or if you were to do
it over the network,
that would take about 51
days to transfer the data.
You deduplicate it
and compress it.
That ends up being
about 100 terabytes,
which you could write in
10 days over the network.
But then what you have to worry
about is, in those 10 days,
there's going to be
change rate generated,
which means then you have to
recursively catch up on that
and recursively catch up on the
next and the next and the next.
And, of course, we're
assuming there's no growth.
So the idea here is that that
100 terabytes deduplicated
and compressed is written
into the Transfer Appliance.
The Transfer Appliance to put
on the truck and sent across.
Let's assume it takes two weeks
to get that data to show up
in your GCS bucket.
So in those 14 days, you've
generated another 20 terabytes
worth of data.
So now you're at the position
that you were earlier, which
is, how do I transfer that?
Do I do it over the network?
Do I get another
Transfer Appliance?
So you don't want to do
either one, preferably.
What you want to do is at the
bottom, where you're actually
sending your incrementals--
which is two terabytes
considering it's 2%--
to GCS directly.
So now we're talking
about, mathematically,
about five hours to
transfer that data.
So think of it as two buckets.
You'll end up with
one bucket that
has your fulls or your
auxiliary copy data,
and you'll have your
second bucket, which will
have your incremental data.
And from a platform
perspective, there's
no complication, no
issue, for the system
to be able to pick up
where the data lives.
So if you want to be
able to do a restore,
it knows it to read
from bucket one,
and incremental bit
from your new bucket
versus from your old bucket
in order to pull that.
So the important aspect here
is that that 28 terabytes
or three days, because
generating that data,
while the appliance
is on the truck,
and then you can
finally catch up.
So the better approach
really is at the bottom
where you're just sending
incrementals straight
to GCS over your network.
And what that end
up being is, yeah, I
can keep my network
at a gigabit.
I don't have to provision an
immense amount of bandwidth
just to account for the
500 terabytes, which
would be a one-time transfer.
And hopefully, you never have
to transfer the 500 terabytes
back, so you never really
have to worry about that.
Ben.
BEN CHONG: Thanks, Deepak.
All right, so just
a quick summary.
So we have a Cloud Transfer
Service for cloud-to-cloud
transfers, gsutil for
on-prem-to-cloud transfers
if you have enough bandwidth.
And, obviously, if you
don't have enough bandwidth,
there's Transfer Appliance.
[MUSIC PLAYING]